war continues to ravage Europe but help  is on the way every able-bodied young  man is lining up to serve his country  [Music]  even little Timmy is doing his part  collecting scrap metal nice work today  who cares Lee the movie already hey show  some respect  meanwhile overseas our brave boys are  showing the Axis powers that the price  of freedom is never too high let's go  get on with it  Hey just start the cartel you want to  shut up together with our life we just  don't know when to give up do you yes  all day  Hey  pick on someone your own size sometimes  I think you like getting punched I had  him on the ropes many times is this oh  you're from Paramus now you know it's  illegal to lie on the enlistment form in  seriously Jersey you get your orders  1:07 'the sergeant James Barnes shipping  out for England first thing tomorrow I  should be going  come on well last night here you cleaned  up why where we going future  you  [Music]  you